(soft music)
♪ Yeah, Okay, is tea with Garyvee ♪
♪ Siping in some tea ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all my shit for free ♪
♪ This is tea, with Garyvee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Good morning Beaner nation
hope everybody is super well.
Morning.
Let's give some shout outs.
Raman and Joe Hyannis what's good?
Brock Miller what's good?
Jimmy P in the building
Jessica Bella, Marsianno what is up?
Axel blind heart test.
Danielle Hart here with best BBQ show
What's up?
Big shout out to all the platforms.
Before we get right into
the show let's share it up.
Really interested in
as many people sharing this as possible.
If you're on Facebook,
absolutely share or restream.
If you are on Twitch,
big shout out to everybody on Twitch.
YouTube if you can just
click that a URL up there
and share it in Facebook or Twitter
or your Facebook groups or text one homie
and Twitter family just retweet.
Let's share this out.
Let's get some new hearts
and minds into this session.
We've been helping a lot of people
and I wanna get to that place
in the world.
Dustin, what's good?
What's good with you?
- Not much, I just got the Twitch alert,
which is good.
- You mean the push
notification that I'm live?
- Yeah.
- I appreciate that.
I like the sketches we're
putting out on Instagram.
- Yeah.
- They remind me of (mumbles)
I'm sure it's derived off
of that but those older,
like funny meme kind of things.
- You good?
- Yup.
- Awesome.
- At the end of the show
today we're gonna have
the Garyvee TV promo thing
just so you know.
So how about those Knicks?
(laughs)
- Dustin when we do is there,
I guess are we gonna throw up the
Twitter URL to that
so that everybody here can share it?
- Yeah.
- How crazy.
What Dustin dropped the dime on of course
is we've started something
super cool on Twitter
so if you don't follow me on Twitter,
you're making a huge mistake.
Dustin by the way,
we need to get like all
sorts of stuff for Twitch
like where's our team on that.
- So here's the thing.
In order for you to
get all those little nice things
we have to be either an
affiliate or a partner
- Got it.
- But then that would
limit you to not be able
to stream other platforms.
So it's kind of like a not sure,
- Catch 22.
- Yeah.
I'm sure you'd rather be
everywhere then committed.
(laughs)
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- Alright.
- Okay.
I don't know if that's true
I'll figure it out.
- Yeah I'm sure
- You can figure that out
- Yeah.
- Okay cool.
Let's get him to this show
(laughs)
- Gary what's up man?
- The legend is in the building.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Real pleasure, man.
I'm about you and your whole crew
as you know we're friendly.
I'm pretty friendly
with plenty of your fam
and it's really good to see you DJ Paul
- Yeah
- Appreciate all the work
you put in man.
Especially I appreciate and
listen to a lot of your music.
- Thank you, man thank you.
I saw something long time ago
when you was on my Instagram.
I think you liked or commented
on something or something
it was weird.
I was like, wow, cool
but I've been following
you for a long time.
So I appreciate that man.
- Appreciate you back, man.
It's a good way to start.
Let's go, what's cooking?
What can I help you with?
- I got a couple of questions
and I don't know if you
have time to answer both
or just one of them.
I do a real estate on the
side outside of music.
I do really go with it
and I try to help out my fans as well
so I answer questions for them
so this is a big question
that they always ask me
I have my answers about it,
but I wanted to ask a pro like you.
- Please
- One of them is a buying versus renting.
What you think is best?
- It's really interesting.
Believe it or not,
the answer can be either.
Let me explain.
Obviously, when you're
buying you're creating
institutional value and wealth creation
and over the long period of time,
that becomes an ROI positive thing.
Buying real estate has been tried
and true in our society for 100 years.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And plus, so I'm a fan.
However, I see a lot of people
overextending themselves on the buy,
which then takes their cash
out of the equation on other things.
Of course, if you bought
a home 10 years ago,
you would have done well.
But if you put that same money
into Amazon stock and just rented,
you would have done much better.
- Yeah
- And so people don't think about options.
So is buying a home usually
as long as your neighborhood
doesn't go to shit out of nowhere,
an ROI positive financial event over time?
Yes.
Does it multiply the same way
that if you made a smart
decision at that time,
with that same cash?
No.
Number two, most people when they buy,
extend themselves too much,
they buy the most
expensive house they can.
They wipe all their
liquid on the down payment
and then they kind of live their life
to just make their mortgage payments.
And it takes them out of opportunities.
I bought a lot of stock
during the pandemic the first week.
- Yeah
- Netflix, Amazon they
were at like record lows
now a month later that record highs.
Like that was an opportunity
but if you didn't have cash to do that,
you missed it.
So the answer is both.
You have to be thoughtful on it
and you have to know
where you are in your life cycle
and more importantly,
what are you gonna do with
that cash if you're renting
because just sitting on
the cash versus buying
that's not a good idea.
- Yeah, 'cause a lot of people
are not as smart as you
when it comes to stocks
and when to buy and what to buy.
Alot of people are more
familiar with property
- And especially some
of our mutual fan base,
if you're in areas that
are on their way up
getting gender fied,
getting cleaned up,
you could buy some homes
and places that used
to look kind of dirty.
- Yeah
- You could start buying
up those homes on the cheap
and really doing quite well.
There's a couple of places I'm looking at
in Jersey on that.
Or you could go buy a house in what used
to seem like a good neighborhood,
but then they put some sort of change
to the highway and it fucked your shit up.
Listen, everything's a
gamble to your point.
DJ Paul is the number one
thing I want people to do
is buy what they know.
Even though I hate them
because I hate the bulls
with all my heart.
I told all my friends,
I didn't do it cause I
had too much emotion.
But I told all,
all my friends to buy Scottie
Pippen and Rookie cards.
Right?
I'm gonna pull up the thread actually
it's some crazy shit.
I told all my friends to buy them
because I knew this
documentary was coming right.
- Oh wow, yeah.
That documentary is crazy.
- And so that Rookie card went
up literally from 30 to 300.
- Wow.
- That's it like that's
10 X on your return
and anybody could have done that
if they were paying attention.
- Yeah.
- So bet on what you know.
- The next question
and my last one didn't I get out of here.
If you have like,
I own a lot of multimillion dollar homes
in big cities that I rent out
and I saw somebody said that
if you have a house
now is probably of the time to sell it
because millennials not going
to be into homes as much.
What do you think about that?
- What I think about that
is if you're renting out those homes,
you're gonna win because
there is a movement
in the youth to not buy but to rent
and they're still gonna want
to live in fancy places.
So your gonna be making the value
on the ownership.
I actually think the renting
market is going to explode
in the premium market.
So if you're sitting on
that kind of inventory,
I actually think you're sitting well.
- Okay.
- I think you're gonna have more demand.
I think you're gonna be able to
increase those prices.
- I thought the same thing too.
I just didn't know what
security be more an
issuing what they go for condos
versus a stand alone home.
- No, the plenty are gonna
for stand alone homes
because a lot of them are gonna buy
into what I'm saying
which is like don't own it
have it five years.
When you'll be get caught
the only variable there
that really get caught
as if you go through
years of everybody renting
and then one year the market switches
and people go back to buying homes,
then you'll need to sell it.
But I think you'll make
the institutional value
over that time.
Listen, good property
is good property always
and forever period,
whether it's renting or selling.
- Yeah.
- Period.
- Alright.
- Alright bet.
- We appreciate that man.
- Take care of yourself man.
Keep doing it
We appreciate it.
All right, let's keep this going.
That was fun.
- Hi Gary.
- Hey Adriana, how are you?
- Good.
I feel like this was
like the perfect setup.
- Loving.
- Because I am a real estate agent.
- Perfect.
- And you guys were just talking
about real estate,
so funniest shit ever.
So first off,
thanks for having me on
- Of course.
- So I do have two questions for you.
So first question is
I have all of the major
social media channels.
So I have Twitter, LinkedIn,
Instagram, Tiktok, Snapchat
I have a WhatsApp,
I have my website,
I have everything.
Cause I just opened up
my own real estate office
about a year ago.
So I do a pretty decent job I guess,
of posting content on most of them
we've gotten better for sure.
Since January, since I've
found that 164 pieces
of content slide show thing.
Yeah, that definitely helps
cause I do like a lot of videos.
I do a market update video
that I post once a month
kind of been doing that
for like two years.
So I started doing more
like homeownership tips,
like helping define different
terms and stuff like that.
And they take like a three minute video
and crop it into like
smaller one minute section
stuff like that.
So that definitely helps.
My one thing is as far as growth,
you always say, try to comment on,
blow up on Twitter and
comment on everything
with all the different
social media channels
that I haven't been a one woman show.
Would it be better for
me to devote less time
to each one of them or just pick
one at a time for like a week now?
(laughs)
- I think less time
I think spreading yourself is better.
Here is why.
I think people's egos are wrapped up
in their following count.
- Okay
And so they get caught up in,
if you focused on one channel,
you'd be more likely
to get that one channel
to have more followers.
And that's what I think
people are aiming for.
When I'm aiming for is actual business.
And by going everywhere,
you're tasting different dynamics,
which is teaching you how
to be a better creator.
You don't give a shit if
you sell a home on TikTok
or LinkedIn or YouTube or
Facebook you're in a business.
Most people wanna focus on one thing
because their entire framework,
when it comes to social media
is completely based on followers.
- Right.
- It's a fucked up thing
that I'm trying to destroy.
I'm actually advocating behind the scenes
for all social networks
to hide follow account.
- Now and that makes sense.
Because I do rather than focus on that,
I do tend to focus more on
actual valuable content.
So I don't really post
a whole lot of stuff of,
I sold this house or why sold that house.
Because I feel like people
don't really give a crap.
Unless I sold it to them, they
don't care that I sold it.
- I would say here and
there spreading that out.
Isn't bad because it shows people that you
are selling homes, which is fine.
Yeah, I think your
question is predicated on a
social media question,
excuse me, a social
media perception question
versus an actual business question.
What if one of your videos goes viral
on TikTok and that becomes the thing
that most helps your business.
That's not something
that would have happened
if you most focused
on just getting the most
followers you can on one platform.
People are absolutely
obsessed with figuring out how
to get followers when what
they should be figuring out
is how to get happiness
and how to get the business
result they're looking for.
And followers are an indication
that you're hitting a nerve
and people are interested,
but that's the byproduct,
not the goal.
And I think people are making it the goal
and that's where their
strategies are breaking down.
- That makes sense.
So don't worry as much about the followers
and worry more about
where my leads are coming from.
So to speak and how many
people broadcasting me.
- Slash realizing that
your in other places
that you're learning
and that something may happen somewhere
that you could have never seen.
And then like something
may happen on TikTok
that makes you say,
Oh, now TikTok needs
to be 50% of my energy
and the rest need to be 5% each.
But you would have never known that
if you weren't giving 5%
of your energy to TikTok.
- Absolutely.
- That makes sense.
- Got it.
- Eggs and baskets, right?
- Okay, Yeah.
- Eggs and baskets.
- Okay.
And second question is actually
for my husband.
He actually is the one
that turned me on to you
like four years ago.
And I was one of those
people that was like, okay,
he's a little bit too much for me.
Yeah, no.
(laughs)
- I actually was one of those people
that thought you were (mumbles)
- I get it.
- I feel like
at the time was not there like mentally
- I get it.
- So since then.
- Yap.
- Now we're better.
So my husband knows...
- Just so I can learn a little bit.
Was there a piece of content
that kind of triggered it?
Was there a moment where
the switch is like,
wait a minute,
this guy's not full of shit,
this guy actually can help?
- It was but it actually
wasn't even one of yours.
- I love that.
- So I started listening
to a lot of like Jim Rohn
and Napoleon Hill and
started listening to like
a lot of stuff that they
like said in their books
and they went back and like
started listening to...
I listened to one of your videos.
Oh my God.
Like he's saying the same exact thing
that they're saying.
- Interesting.
- He's just saying it differently.
- That's cool.
- Like your mindset thing that you have
about like owning the jets.
- Yes.
- Napoleon Hill actually
talks about that in his book
"Think and Grow Rich".
'Cause you have that
undying focus for that
and nothing you do.
That's a concept that you
probably didn't even know
that you had.
(laughs)
- All right, go ahead for your husband.
- So for my husband,
he didn't grow up with a whole lot
of structure or self discipline.
- Okay.
- So his main tip that
he would want to know
is having grown up with no discipline
and having no very little self discipline
as an adult.
Is there a way that he can,
I guess, learn to acquire
that self discipline
as an adult?
- Well, what's the discipline in?
- Just in general.
He wants big dreams but...
- It's not gonna work?
- Yeah.
- He's full of shit.
- Yeah, in a lot of ways.
- Well, let's get him on the show
and let me get a crack at it.
You have a very tricky
spot in this relationship
because you love him.
And even the way you're delivering it,
I can see that it's not like the worst.
You just want something good to happen.
So you have to find the balance
of not actually perpetuating
it by over coddling him
and entitling him at the same token,
telling him constantly,
like you also do something about
is gonna hurt feelings.
It's a tricky game.
- Absolutely.
- My big thing is that,
one of the things that I
love to tell people is like,
this is simply about,
results or results.
Like everyone has excuses.
So Jessica Fellz says here,
I've major discipline problems.
LoL.
Here's the reality.
And this is a really cold.
This isn't a tea,
this isn't even a dirty tea.
This is ice cold tea for
everybody this morning.
The results are always right.
What I mean by that is,
if you're not winning,
it is 100% your fault.
Not 99, not 98,
not your mom's,
not the systems,
not this one deal fell through,
not Oh God Corona happened now
100% is your fault.
And I think people that lack discipline
or talk about big game
but never do shit,
need to be reminded 24 seven, 365,
sometimes cold, sometimes sweet tea,
but they need to be
delivered every single time
100% of this is on you.
Oh, you haven't achieved that thing yet?
That's you.
Not the neighborhood
not how I grew up.
I grew up on discipline
Like that's called excuses.
- Right?
- Many people grew up with
shit family situations
in the shit hood
with drug moms
and all that shit
and went on to fucking do shit
because they had thank God for them
the DNA, the serendipity,
they met somebody along the way.
Honestly, in a lot of ways,
that is what drives the shit out of me.
Adriana I want to be that person
because I had people around me.
There's a level of gratitude and guilt
that makes me wanna be
the person for people
that they stumbled across
on YouTube or Twitch,
or what have you, that
helped them get happier.
And happiness starts with accountability.
Period and the end of story.
Period end of story.
Like the end,
you don't like America, move.
Sweden's fucking fresh.
Your mom drags you down, move.
No, but then I'll hurt her if...
No.
That's you making you.
Every person watching
this right now is one...
Every person watching this right now
has the internet
because that's where I am right now.
If you have the internet,
you are 100% accountable.
And so, the way you could help him
is suffocate him sometimes with sweetness
sometimes with a little bitter herbs
of your honey, that's you,
that's not Ron's fault from work.
That's not your dad's fault that he,
I have no idea what the situation
I'm just getting thrown out those names.
(laughs)
- Like this is 100% accountability.
- Yeah.
- Nobody gives a fuck
that you had an unstructured life.
Definitely not your dreams.
Your dreams don't give a fuck
that you had an unstructured life.
If you got fucking dreams,
if you're talking big game,
go fucking execute.
Don't tell me why you can't execute.
Complaining and excuses
are fucking poison,
garbage, losing DNA.
Suffocate them.
- I'm trying
(laughs)
- Suffocating is consistent.
- I'll do as much as I can.
- Yeah, exactly.
But why I'm saying sweet and candor,
you got to mix it
because suffocating means
every time it gets brought up,
you don't let it go by.
- Yeah.
No, yes Ma'am
You can't be the yes woman.
You got to be no,
but sometimes it's like,
honey, you're fucking full of shit.
And you walk out of the room.
That's a (humming)
Other times it's like baby,
I know that you fucking didn't have it
like that as a kid.
But the punchline is
there is no time machines.
You can't go back.
So if you're gonna fucking
go do all these things,
you got to do it now.
That's sweet, that's (humming)
sometimes (humming) sometimes (humming)
But never, yeah, you're right.
Anytime you say yeah, you're right
to a complainer and a dweller
you're fucking feeding the beast.
- Okay
- You're enabling that bullshit.
- Yeah.
(humming)
Never you're right.
- Never just ignore it.
It's always say something.
- It's suffocating.
- Alright cool, I will do it.
(humming)
- Okay
- Good.
- I will do that.
Awesome Gary, thank you.
- You got it.
- Take care, bye.
- Have a good rest of your day.
- That was good.
I'm into that shit.
Dustin I believe in that shit, bro.
- Yeah.
That's something me and
my girlfriend actually
working on all the time.
Just not feeding each other.
- Not enabling bad behavior.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
Let's keep it going.
That was good.
What's up my man?
- What's up fam?
I don't know if you remember me,
but I was the guy that treated you,
that would drive my
wheelchair up to New York
to take your hands.
And I just want to thank you for
what you've done for me in the past
and what you continue doing for me.
My question is,
I've done everything you told me to do
on TikTok, on LinkedIn
but Instagram and Twitter.
And I'm in the process of writing a book
and I don't know,
and I don't have the clothing brand
this is my quote, my dominant the today.
Clothing brand, I just don't
know what the next step is to
go further and take it to the next step.
Like I reached out to you,
like the inner speakers you're trying
to do like get more speaking engagements.
Cause I've been doing that a lot
and I just don't know what the next step
is for me to...
- Bcow when you say next step,
what are you trying to accomplish?
Like make the book sell
or get speaking gate.
What's the ROI?
- I'm trying to spread my message.
I don't care if the book sells.
I just wanna do it.
- You can use both.
Then just spread the message.
- Yeah.
- No, stick with me here.
This is an important moment.
I think this will bring you value.
The message will find
its audience over time.
All you can do is put it out.
When I say post everywhere,
all I'm really saying is
put out your story,
put out your message.
And then what ends up happening Bcow is
the market takes over.
- Okay.
- There's been people who
wrote books in the 40s
and 20s that didn't get
fame until they were dead
in the 70s.
Cause somebody read it and put it on.
- Yeah.
- More of my videos will
be consumed after I'm dead
than when I'm alive.
- Yeah.
- You see where I'm going.
If you're actually telling the truth,
that just want to spread the message,
which is my truth.
Then you just spread the message.
Most people actually
are trying to make as
much money as possible,
get as much famous possible.
They're going selfish, not selfless.
When you go fucking selfless,
you have no anxiety.
- Yeah.
- I never thought about it
when it wasn't happening.
It didn't cross my fucking mind.
- Yeah.
And like you said, living your truth,
I know I'm in a wheelchair
and I'm not going to get out
of the wheelchair at all.
I'm gonna be on a wheelchair for the rest
of my life and I'm happy.
Obviously I'm not happy about it,
but it's what it is.
- It's your truth
That's right
- Yeah
And then the whole exception
versus reality thing,
like it was the thing I'm so depressed
about being in a wheelchair, is not.
- I know you are not.
- It's me.
- It's why I love you.
It's why I know you can win,
but I don't want you to get caught up
in bullshit metrics of
money and followers,
if you just need to keep
fucking making content, bro.
- Yeah, and I'm putting stuff out.
- It's just not doing as well
as you want it to do.
- Yeah, exactly.
But I'm also struggling
with like paying for stuff
I wanna get lights on my wheelchair.
That's $700 I don't have.
- Okay, well, guess what?
I'm buying you lights for your wheelchair.
- Really?
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
You and Dustin are
gonna connect right now.
You're gonna send me your PayPal
and I'm going to send you $700
and now you got fucking
lights on your wheelchair.
- Okay.
- Now you can go spread your message.
My whole thing is I want to tell people
to do the best they can...
- So do that.
- With their abilities.
And that's what I've been doing.
- Keep doing it.
- Okay.
- Have you thought about flipping?
- I don't have a car.
- No.
I'm talking internet only.
- Flipping what, like?
- Anything, obviously I think
about sports cards, anything,
buy something for $25,
repost it for $45.
Have you thought about it?
- I've done that.
But they closed the
selling shop close to me
I can't really drive.
- Remember what I said Bcow,
no, internet only.
Buy a lot of wrestling figures on eBay.
- Yeah
- Put them home.
Sell them off individually,
make the 100% profit.
- Okay, I can do that.
I'll do that.
- I think you can do that Bcow.
I think you can really get good at that.
- Yeah.
That's what I'm trying to do.
- Bcow listen to me.
I know that you want more people
to follow you more people
to see shit.
It can happen
if you just keep going at it
and if your message is good enough.
If it's not, it won't,
that's just the truth.
So one of the things that
people need to worry about is
changing up their message a little bit.
I don't think most people
aren't going deep enough.
I think most people go surface level.
- See, I'm trying to go deep too,
because I'm trying to go deep versus wide.
Like you say,
I'm putting out content and that stuff.
- I want you to go deep and wide.
Right?
I want to go deep on every platform.
- Yeah.
That's what I'm trying to do.
- Listen, it's a long game, bro.
- Yeah.
- It just is.
- And I just started, like,
I really just started off and I'm trying
to get my message out there
by selling these shirts
and stuff and that kind of stuff.
And I don't know.
I needed this to give
me a little shout out.
- A little boost.
Well, good, I'm always here.
Couple of things.
This was super productive.
First of all, a fuck load of people
are probably following you right now
on Instagram and Twitter.
Let's see what's going on there.
So that's good.
That will give you a boost in the arm.
I'm all about boosts in the arm.
I love giving boosts in the arm.
Like I'm here to give
you a boost in the arm.
Right?
So there's that.
So here's a big one.
I didn't even realize this.
I haven't followed you yet.
So boom you just got my follow
that fucking matters.
Right?
That's nice.
You're at 843, you're at 846.
I don't know what you started at
when you got on here.
- Yeah, I was at,
in the eight hundreds.
- Well, good, you're
about to get over 1000.
Watch this.
Here comes the Vayner Nation
everyone's going to come hard.
Now that they see you're smiling,
this shit's going to get real crazy.
Every fucker on here is about
to follow you.
So that's good.
That's a little boost in the arm.
Another boost in the arm is
I just bought you fucking
lights for the wheelchair.
Now we've got fucking lights.
That's fucking huge.
- Because I drive my wheelchair.
I've literally drive my wheelchair.
I've driven over 1000 miles in six months.
- Yeah, you need fucking lights.
You can't be dangerous out there.
- No we can't.
- Now you got lights, right?
- Yeah.
- So that's good.
So here's the boosting arm.
You got lights.
- Yeah.
- You're gonna send me the link
and you're gonna give Dustin
the link to where you want,
which lights you want
and your PayPal, right?
- Yeah.
I have to order them through
the through the manufacturer.
- Actually so then I'll just
wire you the $700 on PayPal.
- Okay.
- So that will get done
right after this call.
Like you'll talk to Dustin.
So that's good.
You know what another
boost is looking at this
looking at this bro.
1100.
- (mumbles)
- What's that?
- I see them on my phone.
I see them coming in like fast.
- You're on the phone right now
and you're getting all
the push notifications.
- Yes.
- That feels good, right?
That's a little dorfim hit
for the fucking Bcow this morning.
- Very good
- Yeah, that's right, my man.
- I still wanna come up
there and kick your ass
in Ice Hockey forNintendo.
- Bro. I'm gonna beat
your fucking brains in.
- No, you cannot.
- You don't know me.
I'm not gonna hold back.
I don't give a fuck about anything.
I'm gonna beat your fucking stolen.
(mumbles)
- We'll see Bcow.
You can bring a friend
to and get three hands.
I'm gonna beat the fucking, both of you.
I'm not losing to you in
fucking Ice Hockey for Nintendo.
- I can try.
I used to play it all the time.
- I don't give a fuck Bcow
my brain won't let me lose to you.
- Okay.
- All right, I'll see you on Twitch.
Talk to Dustin we'll get you the lights,
congratulations on all your new followers
and remember slow and steady
on those wheels, brother.
It's gonna take some time.
Don't get down.
Day by day.
- Yeah.
I'm just trying to do the next step.
I really wanna do it and I feel...
- You know I seel patience for free.
- Yeah.
- It's patience , bro.
You just started.
- Yeah.
- And it's gonna be huge boost.
A bunch of people probably DM you
right now with opportunities.
So take up all those people that want
to do podcasts and collaborations.
Use this as a springboard moment for you.
You got lights and you got fucking a boost
on your Instagram and
that's gonna get you going.
- Yeah.
I can go from there.
Thank you again.
- You're welcome brother.
Talk to you soon.
- Alright.
- Bye.
Let's keep it going.
Yup
Dustin?
- Yup.
- They don't realize that I would
I would beat Bcow 12 to nothing
and I saw that stand up
and go get right in his face.
When I go into competition, Gary,
that's a different fucking dude.
- I know.
- You've seen it.
- Yeah.
- When did you see it the most?
What's your favorite
competition Gary story?
- I remember you were in the Twitch studio
and then you're playing,
I don't remember what
game you were playing,
but it's that one photo we posted
of you were either like,
- Oh, going nuts.
My arms looked huge.
I think I asked if we had taken enstema.
I was tired up.
Yeah, alright.
Let's keep going.
Hi Rachel.
- Hello
- How are you?
- Hi, I'm good thank you.
That was so great what you did with Bcow.
I love that.
- Thank you.
- I visualized this moment over and over
(mumbles)
So I thank you so much for having me.
You're making this the best day
of my life, I'm sure .
I am actually stuck
and I feel like I'm missing
a piece of a puzzle.
So that's why I'm here with you.
And I wrote down a few notes just
to give you really short background.
And then I'll ask my question.
So about three and a half years ago,
I quit corporate and I
hated every minute of it,
but I did it because I
really wanted to experience.
I liked the money,
I like the car,
I liked all the benefits.
But in my heart and blood and soul
I'm just a real entrepreneur.
And I just want to be located independent
and travel the world.
I've been living abroad for many years
but I never ever take the leap of faith.
I don't believe in that.
So I just work.
So before I left and before I quit,
I really started building what you call
leverage and credibility and all of that.
So, meanwhile while I'm here now
I published books
I co-authored books, I did two TEDx Talks.
I have a bunch of online courses on Udemy.
I started really focusing on YouTube,
put all my content there
and I coach a few clients.
But I also have a teaching
job at university part time
because I need the paycheck.
- I get it, smart.
So you're practical and ambitious.
- Yes.
But I have to say,
I have to add that
I used to be super shy,
low self confidence
and I taught myself everything.
So that's the message I wanna bring out
in my YouTube content
and everything is like,
you guys, you can learn it.
You can learn this,
- I was there.
- Yeah, everything that you talk about,
the mindset, the positivity
I created this life for me.
I'm able to travel.
Not because I'm lucky.
No, because I created,
because my thoughts create my reality.
Yeah.
- There's no luck.
There's circumstances and execution.
There is no luck.
- Absolutely.
- Luck is a loser word.
There's circumstances
and there's execution.
Now, of course there's circumstances
and maybe luck and circumstances
are the same word but like no question,
like you can make so much
happen for yourself.
And if you're defeated by
it's already been written,
then you're not gonna do anything.
- Totally.
And I stopped comparing
myself to other people
because you look at the others like, Oh,
they have it all
and I don't have anything
(mumbles)
- You don't know anything about them.
- Exactly.
- They make that all on paper.
You said you had the house, the cars,
but you weren't happy fuck that.
I don't give a shit about no.
I want to know what their soul's about.
- Yup, absolutely.
And so that's really what
I wanna do at least like,
I just wanna continue my life
living a life without regrets,
but also inspiring people to,
Hey, don't stay stuck
in a job that you hate
and just do what you love
and live that life without regret.
So my drive is like,
I don't wanna grow old and thinking, Oh,
what if I had done it?
No, I don't wanna be that person.
So I wanna live.
So my question is,
well first of all,
I could use, you love to boost.
I would love to have your boost
on my YouTube channel
because I put all my content.
- There you go.
- Thank you so much Dustin,
thank you Gary.
And my question really is
what am I missing here?
How can I monetize this more
so that I can quit that teaching job,
and just be fully my own boss.
Using all of that content I
give, but I'm not monetizing.
- Are you asking?
(laughs)
- Not enough.
I knew you gonna say that but I just...
- It's cause I'm listening to you.
Everyone's always like
Garry you tackle everybody
I'm fucking listening.
If you started from a place of insecurity,
the number one place
where people are insecure
is the ask.
- Yeah.
- You might've addressed a lot of areas.
The next place we need to boost up
is your ability to feel
confident for the ask.
- 'Cause I mean, I post
I share, I give value,
I have coaching clients.
I know I'm good at this
because they always say,
I over deliver.
- You have to ask more
and you have to charge more.
It's just practice.
What's amazing is, I
know you're gonna do it
'cause you've already done the first part.
This is literally just asking for more.
If I ask you right now,
if I was Johnny Magoo and I
said I want you to be my coach,
what would be the price?
- Way too low,
about $1,500 for four months.
- Right?
So little less than $400 a month.
- Mm hmm
- So now make it five.
Now the next person that asks,
make it $2,000 for four months.
Now that's 500,
the next person, 600,
the next person, 700.
And then what you'll learn is
people said yes all day long at 500,
they said yes all day long at 600,
but at 700,
you're getting pushback
only half say, yes,
that's still good.
At 800 everyone says, no,
the news you found your market.
You're about 750.
But not when one person says no,
when 20 people say no.
And so you need to push
the envelope of your costs
and then on your content,
you need to ask more often and say,
Hey everybody, I'm taking
on five more clients today.
This is the video.
It's not gonna get as many
likes or as many views,
cause it's a sell.
But you can be like today, I'm
taking on five more clients.
Let me tell you why I think I'm great.
Let me maybe you take a video into a zoom
with three people that use you as a coach
and put the testimonial in there.
And then you sell five people.
Jab, right, hook.
You have to be okay with asking,
especially when you believe in it.
You've heard this from me.
Like the reason I keep
pushing wine techs right now
today we're selling a $95
Cabernet that got 95 points
from the best wine magazine for $39.
When wine.com is selling it for $95
when the Vino is selling it for $104,
Of course, I'm gonna tell,
everybody's got father's day coming up.
They could buy something for $39.
That is $100 value.
Like of course I feel good about throwing
that right hook
and you feel good about you being good?
- Yeah, I know I'm good.
It's just that I do.
I feel like I want to
put more energy into this
people are not really
asking me for coaching,
I guess, because I'm not asking,
- Because you are not asking that's right.
Yes, you have to make them aware
that you're open for business.
Like it's okay.
And it's okay when you go for it
and nobody orders it too.
You're like, okay, Gary got me hyped.
You rewatch the video,
you put on some Rocky music
and you go in
and nobody buys, that's okay too.
You go right back to providing value.
- So you're just asking posts,
just asking posts like that.
- Yup.
- Okay.
Just be my client
and grab your coaching session.
- Make a video once a month and say,
this is the every month as you guys know,
like literally, tomorrow you're like,
hey guys, it's Rachel again.
Like every month going forward,
one of my YouTube videos is gonna be about
signing up some coaching clients
'cause I'm really excited about it.
And I'm at a point in my life,
it's just transparency, right Rachel?
I'm just gonna act as you right now.
And some of you may or may not know
I'm gonna put in my life where
I've got another job as well.
And I'm on the verge
of being full coach.
And I wanna give more energy
to my coaching clients.
And if I tip over and
get another 10 clients,
I can do that.
So I'm doing a special today.
Like spoke to Garyvee the other day
and I'm maybe raising my prices,
but for anybody who signs up now,
I'm gonna honor my retroactive price.
Next month I'm gonna be in my new pricing.
I really feel proud of it.
If you wanna speak to some of my clients,
when you email me,
I've asked all seven of them.
Two of them said, yes,
they'd be references.
You're happy to talk to them,
but I'm telling you right now.
I really believe that
the investment you make
with me will be ROI positive for you.
And so (humming) couple of other things
which I think you should go to six months,
four months is just too much.
- Yeah,
I just gave an example,
but I have like different packages.
Yeah.
- I wouldn't have six your floor.
- Okay, yeah.
- You see where I'm going?
I would make six your floor
just cause it gives you
more time to make an impact.
- Totally.
- It helps, four months
it takes a month to get kind of cozy,
by the time you're going,
you're in that renewal cycle,
which for you comes for in on the sales.
So I wanna give you a
little more time to breathe.
This is fucking business strategy.
- Yeah, true.
My YouTube videos are all about
tips and advice on gaining clarity
and the confidence and the
mindset and overcoming fears.
But what you just said,
is it more like a live or something
do more live.
- No.
- Okay.
- By the way.
Yes.
Live and YouTube video.
Like for one day your salesman, Rachel.
- Okay.
It doesn't have to be a live
that's what you're saying?
- It's gonna be both.
I want you to go a live.
I want you to go up like
yeah the 15th of the month.
Every day you do selling
your coaching, it's fine.
- Yeah.
- You are allowed.
- I used to do Facebook live
but I wanna do YouTube live.
- If you choose your number one platform
you have to go there.
If you have an email
service, email that out.
We call it a launch on team Gary.
If I'm like, Hey, we're launches.
That means everybody's getting hit.
- Yeah.
- Every channel, email,
text platform, social,
(clapping)
- Yeah, and I have enough things to sell.
My online courses, my books,
Ask.
- You need one Saturday
selling Saturday, selling
Sunday one day a week,
one day a month, excuse me,
where you just sell and that's okay.
Maybe you go on live for eight hours
and answer Q&A
and the whole time you're selling.
Like you need a sell day.
- Yeah, makes sense.
Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yeah, can I have 20 seconds
because I really want to shout out
my little brother, he's amazing.
I miss him and I love him.
And he's a barber
and he just puts such an amazing content
on his Instagram.
And so his Instagram handle
is Barbershop Rejinald.
And he's just really tried to grow.
- How do you spell Reginald?
- R-E-J-I-N-A-L-D, Rejinald.
- Barber shop.
- Barbershop Reginald.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, Rachel.
- Wow, thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome.
Bye bye.
See, that was a sell.
She sold her brother's profile.
She's got it in her.
Let's keep it going.
- Gary, what's going on, man?
- What's good Nick?
Where you from?
- I'm from Topeka, Kansas.
- That's what's up?
- Hey man just wanted to say, thank you.
And to let that
this moment makes me extremely happy, man.
I feel super honored to be on your show
and if I could get a virtual
cheers for my birthday
that would be super awsome.
- How old are you, 22?
- 29, appreciate that.
- Looking good, bro.
- Thank you.
So my question here
I really had two
but so I work insurance right now
and the first question I have is
how can I bring value in?
And as a consumer for you, Gary,
what would you say on this?
How can I bring value
without coming across
as a salesman?
- One more time.
How do you bring value as to other people
to then do business with you?
- Yes.
- By watching what I do, right?
Like there's a lot of people
who buy their wine now from my dad's store
from Empathy Wines because I
bring them value at all times.
And then occasionally
I'd mentioned what I do
or what I'm passionate about.
Right?
So the way you bring value
without being too selly
is by not being selly.
- Right.
- But also like the last lady
being okay with asking
for the sale once in a while.
So you put out as much content,
whether it's about Kansas,
whether it's about Esports,
whether it's about insurance,
whether it's about beard culture,
you get people to know you
I'm being serious though.
Your beard might be the single reason
you sell the most insurance.
Insurance is boring.
- That's what I'm saying.
- I know what you're saying.
Why do you think there's
Geico and Progressive?
And they like flow and
like Snoopy for MetLife
insurance is so fucking boring.
They have to create like characters.
- Right.
And I don't want to do,
like what you've said in an
interview before is like,
I don't wanna sell fear.
- Right.
That's one reason,
like you said that you
wouldn't sell insurance is
because of like how you sell it.
- Well, I would sell practicality though.
Some people are like, what if he dies?
That's fear.
But if you're like,
Hey listen, unfortunately as we all know,
one day something will happen
and it's nice to have this in place right?
You see where you see where I'm going.
- Right.
- Okay.
Sorry, I don't want to interrupt you.
- You are not interrupting me ever.
- Alright.
So the second question really is
how does someone find their passion?
- By tasting things.
Like how do if you love surfing
if you've never fucking surfed.
- And I looked into all
the time say that man
and so I figured
that would be your answer.
- So let me ask you a question
to make it even more valuable
to your brother.
What do you think might be your path?
If I'm like, yo bro, 30 days,
you're just gonna do 30 different things.
Like what are some of the
things that come to mind?
- I mean music
I love cooking.
- Have you ever made a video on YouTube
of you cooking something?
- Not like a video,
but like I've posted
like what I've cooked.
- What about a video?
Why don't you make a video tonight?
Take your phone,
set it up and cook and put it
and post it on YouTube and post it on IGTV
and see what the fuck happens.
- Okay.
- That's actually how you do it brother.
- Right.
I've been working on that.
Like, I mean,
that's why I'm on this video right now.
Like I will admit like it's execution.
Like you're absolutely right.
- It always is.
- You posted twice about tea
with JV yesterday.
I said, Hey man,
like it's my birthday.
Can I get on?
I didn't hear anything.
And like, I really wanted to talk to you
and get these things answered.
So I asked it again
and that's when you hit me up.
- And I happen to see it.
And that was that's rare.
You know how many people
watching right now
have asked me 4,700 times
to be on TEA WITH GARYVEE.
It's all serendipity.
But if you didn't,
ask the second time,
I wouldn't have seen the tweet
and we wouldn't have this
moment right now, bro.
- It's execution.
- It's always execution.
Everybody plays out life in their brain
and instead with their hands
and their legs.
Fucking you have to do.
It's only doing.
Everything that plays in the head
is all insecurities and fucking bullshit.
You got to take fucking positive thoughts
and put them to action.
It all comes down to not giving a fuck
what people think
is why I spend so much time on it.
It's being strong enough to put up
that cooking video and
being okay with people
in your life texting you and be like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Which you then reply to
Get the fuck out of my
fucking cooking YouTube video.
You worry about you, mom.
You worry about you, Rick.
You worry about you boyfriend.
Like what do you mean what I'm doing?
I'm living my fucking life.
What the fuck are you doing?
For everybody's watching right now
when you do something,
cause you get inspired right now
and do something new
and somebody goes, what
the fuck are you doing?
Reply with ease.
What do you mean, what
the fuck am I doing?
I'm doing what I wanna do.
What the fuck are you doing?
Get out of my fucking life.
- It's crazy you say that.
Cause I put a Facebook post that said,
if you're ever asked me for
insurance period, delete me.
And like coming from me like that
people they're like, man,
you're so full.
Like what's going on?
Like what's up.
And so, but I did,
I followed it up with love.
The next day I was like, listen,
I hit you too much
with the right hook.
Like I haven't even brought any value.
And I tried to make myself accountable
by saying like, Hey, listen,
I am going to bring you value.
I haven't yet.
So I hear you Gary
I listened to you
and I really appreciate
you having me on here.
And I'm gonna start doing man.
I just had a son this year.
- Congratulations.
- And I got to teach
him the right way, man.
- Teaching the right
way is just about love.
Like you teach them love and kindness
you'll teach them the right way.
If you wanna build on top of that
this is all gravy.
If he's happy and he's kind,
you've taught him the
right way, that's simple.
Layering some of this shit about
business and execution and fulfillment.
That gets a little bit to 201, 301.
That's that next level, right?
So I think you got a shot.
I think you need to
absolutely, just execute.
- Okay.
- Just keep building on this momentum,
rewatch this video as much as you have to.
- I will man.
Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- You got it.
- Omar.
- Gary.
Oh my God.
Man, thank you for having me.
I tried Garry to read it like
six times over the last...
I can't speak man.
- You could speak.
You're doing great brother.
(laughs)
Nice to meet you, where are you from?
- I'm from Egypt.
- Egypt, very nice.
- Am I on the first one for
me to hope on this show.
- I think he might be.
I'm trying to think,
but I think he might be.
- I'm setting a record.
- That's okay baby.
- Okay, let me give you some context
on what my question is.
Alright.
First of all,
I wanna thank you, man.
I got a picture of you.
(laughs)
- Hang on, oh man, you changed my life.
Can you imagine that?
Right.
So let me give me some context, right?
So I'm a 16 year old, to be 17, right?
Okay.
And I create content.
I've been creating like different stuff.
And my main thing is I want people
to get a tap perspective.
You know what I'm saying?
I learn from you and you
want to implement that here.
And like the whole,
like from my community and then go up,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yes.
- So I'm trying to push
them 30 times a day.
I have two on LinkedIn and
a half to one on TikTok
I'm doing everything, I'm hustling
I'm like trying my best.
I know that there's like stuff that I
still must do
and is still that I got to do,
but like I'm in the process.
Right.
But my problem is
not going to give like sugarcoat it.
My problem is I'm not patient enough.
Like, and I don't want it
to like stick it and say,
Oh no, I'm things
So Oh, I like help.
I like, I don't care about judgment.
I don't listen to it.
I got people hopping
on my video, say, yo,
shut the fuck up
and just go play PlayStation, whatever.
But like I'm in my zone
I'm going to give people content
and I'm going to do it.
I don't care what y'all say.
Right.
But I want that.
None of the fame,
like I don't care about the fame
I want
- The impact, the notoriety.
- Yes, exactly.
I want everything.
I want people hopping in my DMs
asking me stuff.
I want to be in the game.
What I'm saying?
- You haven't earn it
you haven't earned it yet.
- You're right.
- But like, that's what I'm stuck at.
- I want to be six foot four
and throw a football 800 yards like
and win 10 Super Bowls as the quarterback,
instead of the owner.
Like I understand wanting
you have an early yet.
- (mumbles)
That's fantastic.
I think you're going
to win the whole thing.
If you can make one little switch,
if you realized working
for all of it tastes better
than all of it.
Your whole game will click.
- Yeah.
You just reminded me of this verse from,
I don't really listen to hip hop.
So it's like,
from J Cole Luxury
is like a beauty in the struggle.
You just reminded me
of that by saying that.
- It's what it is bro
It is what it is.
- I get that.
- Can I tell you something.
- Yeah, go ahead.
I think you're going to look back at this
in 15 years when you have it
and you're going to realize this
was the best part.
Not that you have it.
I swear on my fucking soul
when I didn't have it,
but I knew I was going to get it,
it felt a lot better than
this feels right now.
- So when you were like in 28 and working
in the liquor store.
- I liked being underestimated
I liked people not knowing yet.
- But the problem is like,
when I think about it
I'm 17 and I'm healthy and all things.
- But like, it could
be taken in any moment
and I will leave with no legacy.
I don't care about the legacy that
someone would call
- But you're but you're being,
you're being ideological.
- Oh my gosh.
Someone just said,
what's your Instagram
I'm going to be famous.
- Listen to me Omar.
What is your Instagram?
- It's O M A R S A L I M 0 three.
- Omar Salam 0 three
- Yes, exactly.
- Awesome.
Omar listen to me
you have no choice about that though.
Like to your point,
I understand that it can
be taken at any moment.
If a tree decides to fall
on your head tomorrow,
the punchline is,
that's what it's going to be.
You have no control over that.
You being impatient is
going to make it more likely
that you won't get what you want.
So you're fucking worried about
lightening striking than
something that's almost impossible
by reacting to that with something
that's guarantingly not going
to get you what you want.
So you've decided on some math that
is almost impossible.
I might die,
which is very rare for a 16,
going on 17 year old,
I might die
and then I didn't leave my impact.
Because you've put that
in your mind as a perspective,
you're going to be impatient
and come off as, not as
good of a version as view.
- Okay, I hear you.
But let me tell you
something like the calendar.
When I think about that,
because it moves me what I'm saying.
Like when I told myself
like I'm going to like for 100 years,
I don't think
I'm going to be motivated.
- I don't agree with you.
I think I'm going to
live for a hundred years
I'm motivated as fuck.
Why do they have to be counter feelings?
You can carry both of those.
I've got good news for you.
I already know that you're going
to be motivated regardless
of what you decide,
because you are motivated.
- I am.
- You got a problem though.
The other part matters just as much
your ambition and hunger and motivation.
If not offset by practicality,
patience and execution
will fall on deaf ears
and lead to unhappiness.
- I'm with you on all that patience,
it's just I'm working on it.
- Let me shoot it to you straight brother,
in a real straight tenderous way,
your more interested in the fame
than the process and the fame.
And as soon as you realize that
things will get better.
- I am.
Yes, that's true.
- I know it's true, period, period.
From our period,
- We can put up semi-colon
and then keep going
- No I'm not keeping it.
I'm not giving you that extra little dot
because you're going to get caught.
If you put the fucking admiration
on a pedestal greater than the process,
to get the admiration,
you will limit the upside
of the admiration period.
- I don't really care about the mission.
I just care about impacting people.
What I see 15 years from now
I want to be the host of the (mumbles)
and I'm helping people
and I'm giving.
I want to be in the position.
- I wanted it at 16 too
and I got there
by working my fucking Dick off.
- Yeah, you're right.
- I know, I'm right.
Good news, me too.
Here you go.
28 years from now,
you're looking at them.
The problem is I put
in the fucking work.
- I will, I promise you that.
- I believe you.
Cause you have no fucking choice.
You understand, that's
what's fun about this.
I'm not giving you advice.
I'm giving you the truth.
You have no choice.
If you don't live life,
come up with scenarios,
articulate them in your mind,
figuring out how to be
a communicator of them.
Continue to stay creative.
If you're not the kind of
person that realizes, Oh,
I did this ad for fucking,
wine texts and it worked.
So now I'm going to try it
on my own content.
Oh weird.
It did better than most
of my other.
Like if you're not creative,
if you're not executing,
if you're not patient,
if you're not like good news,
it doesn't matter what
happens here for what I say
or what you say.
If you don't actually put in the work,
if you don't actually execute it,
it won't happen anyway.
It doesn't matter what
you want, everybody wants.
- I'll execute, I know that.
- But the more that you
realize that right now
that your spending more
time thinking about you,
I spent no time
I'm being dead serious on this.
I need you to hear this
because it might help you
and simply gonna help others.
I spent no time thinking
about what this was going
to feel like.
- Well, like can stop like.
- You know what I mean?
Omar, I've never think about,
I think about the day I buy the jets
as the worst day of my life
not the best.
- Because you want the process,
you don't want them.
- Correct.
I need you to take on some of that.
You've already painted more pictures
of thinking what it's going to feel like
when you're at that place
than I did in my whole life.
So I'm trying to say to you, Hey,
this might be something
that's worth debating.
Not that I'm right, but Hey,
this is something for you to think about
because everybody's laying
in their mind thinking
about what it would be like.
I think about what it would be like
to do the work
to get there,
the work, the process,
they fucking negative anxiety.
Like I'm into that shit.
I'm into this.
Like, I like that.
I don't like the, yeah,
you go on.
I like the getting beat up nine rounds in
and fucking figuring it out.
I don't know if you watch my plane.
I don't know if you saw
my video on Instagram,
about me doing that plank challenge.
You need to go look at that again.
- (mumbles)
- Omar, Omar one second
you are chopped in a little bit.
- Hoping this might help
- Okay.
- Omar.
- Am I good or?
- You're goodish.
Omar, listen, if you
watch the plank challenge,
watch it carefully
early on I'm in real trouble.
Like I can tell she's going to beat me
because I don't plank
and it was tired
I hurt my back
like I was going loose
to no excuses.
She was going to win.
She was better.
And in about three minutes in
two minutes in,
I switched it
and I said to her, Carolyn,
I been joking this whole time.
This is hurting.
I can do this for seven minutes.
And it switched the momentum.
It switched the mindset and it put her
in a spot where she was stuck.
She was like, fuck
and so in those two minutes,
when I was in trouble,
I wasn't thinking about
what it would feel like if I had won
I was thinking about
how am I gonna win?
And so my mind went into
a place of like, Ooh,
- (mumbles)
- Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- That's what I want for you now.
- (mumbles) very small question.
I hope I'm not like digging
so much of your time
What would you say if there's one word
or like one thing
that you can see every single 16 or 17,
like this age range, have
personal independent,
what would it be?
- Patience.
- I'm going to start soon.
- It's all patients.
Everybody wants it now because they want
to use the clout of
the thing to offset all
sorts of other things that are going on.
Omar.
People want the clot to use the leverage
of the clot
whether that is to put
a bandaid on their insecurity,
that girls didn't like them
or to prove to their dad
who said they would never be anything.
Like, they're just looking for bandages
of the clout
They're using the clout
to fucking bandage.
I don't want that.
I want people to enjoy the process.
That's actual life.
- Yeah.
I feel you on that one
- That's it bro.
You're chopping, so we gotta go.
Love you brother.
It's too bad.
It was really good talk.
And it sucks that
he's internet got jacked up,
but good fucking show today, Dustin.
- Yeah.
- Speaking of patience
I've been very patient
with this audience Dustin.
I think what I'd like to do
is run the data and everybody
who commented today.
- Okay.
- And if they're not
signed up for winetext,
if they live in America
and one of the States
that can ship to,
I think we should block
them from their ability
to watch it live
Tea with Garyvee.
- What about the under age people?
- Under age is good
people that live in Michigan
and Illinois and Texas good
people live outside of America.
But if you live in
New York, New Jersey,
California, Florida, Virginia,
and you haven't signed up for winetext
and you're over 21 and you're on here.
I want to block them actually.
So let's get the tech team involved.
Let's get really strict, serious here.
Big shout out to Massachusetts
You guys are in.
Listen today's the biggest day
of them all.
I would Pre-Buy your
father's day gift right now,
$95 Cabernet for 39 bucks.
It's ludicrous.
So it's a huge deal.
Maybe the best one
that we've done yet, please, please
If you can't buy from winetext,
please share winetext
that if you don't drink like K Dub here,
let's put winetext.com
in your Twitch stream,
in your Facebook group,
in your Facebook account,
in your Twitter text,
your best wine friend.
Let's do that.
So love you guys.
And sorry for everybody's getting blocked.
We'll miss you.
If this was your last episode of
Tea With Garryvee live
we appreciate you.
You can watch the tape versions, but like,
it was great to have you
part of this community.
And what you're about to see right now
is a video that we made.
I have started a new Twitter channel.
We're we're working on
something really cool.
And Dustin are you gonna be able
to put the URL here
or if actually everybody's
watching right now, please,
as soon as the URL goes up from
this video type in the URL,
that's clickable for all the people.
Jerry Garcia, you're good.
I know you're in Texas,
so you won't get blocked.
But for everybody who's getting blocked.
We'll miss you.
But let's let's check out this.
The people that are going to win
over the next five to seven years
are going to be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
You don't love the process.
This is truth we're talking about
great rules require sacrifice.
All of your actions
have to then map to it.
Backpack, backpack, backpack.
Nobody gives a shit about
where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work,
It's being respectful,
It's being a good person
do that is not just a good idea.
It's there, the flipping's there.
This house right here,
there's $400 in a day.
I stay in my lane
like real fucking tight,
but you can't be crippled.
Everybody who judging themselves,
you're looking at what's in front
of you right now.
You're losing because you're laying
in your bed,
looking at somebody's fucking
glamorous Photo-Shopped picture
of them doing something cool.
And you're envious and you're jealous
and you're impatient.
And it's crippling your upside.
Let me just say it one more time.
If you're confused,
what I just said,
I say, put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value, always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five-year window of your life.
My only answer to you
or anybody like it's just like, try shit.
Turn your egos down
and go work for an apparel
company for 20 years.
Nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed up.
You better work harder.
You better work smarter.
You can't Google stuff.
You're not going to be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
GARYVEETV, my new account.
Check me out.
Hope you enjoy it.